McConnell was taken to a D.C hospital
last night after suffering from a fall a
spokesperson tells CBS News he tripped
at a local hotel during a private dinner
he has been admitted to the hospital
where he is receiving treatment it
remains unclear what his injuries are at
this point or how severe this is not the
first time the 81 year old Senator has
been hospitalized after a serious fall
back in 2019 McConnell took a spill at
his Louisville home he suffered a
fractured shoulder that required weeks
of recovery and physical therapy he had
a triple heart bypass surgery back in
2003 he's also a childhood polio
Survivor McConnell is one of several
Senators who have been hospitalized in
recent weeks including Senators
Feinstein betterman and Casey McConnell
is in his seventh term and this year he
became the longest serving party leader
in Senate history